[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
Knorr I prefer to think of it Dear John
and Hank it's a comedy podcast where me
and my brother John that's that other
person talking will answer your
questions give you to be his advice and
bring you all the week's news from both
Mars and AFC Wimbledon hey John how are
you doing not great it's been a terrible
week Hank as you know here in the United
States it's just been a really hard
difficult painful week I think for
everyone yes and I'm sure that we will
talk about that in the midst of our
podcast questions several of which have
to do with that but first do you have a
short poem for us I do
among the many terrible things that
happen since the last time we recorded
the podcast is that the great Muhammad
Ali died the greatest boxer of all time
who wrote this little poem float like a
butterfly sting like a bee the hands
can't hit what the eyes can't see I'm a
huge Muhammad Ali fan Hank is a great
writer great off-the-cuff poet like the
first great freestyler just a massive
Muhammad Ali fan the world is poor
without him you and that's not that's
not making it up I remember you being a
huge Muhammad Ali fan when I was a kid
and always thinking that was and not a
really understanding it well I think
I've always been attracted to his poetry
but also there's a certain poetry about
the way that that he boxed he's a
complicated person but then again most
of us are and and I was a huge fan of
his and am very very sorry for his loss
all right John let's do with some
questions start off with one from from
Katy who asks dear Hank and John my
friends and I started an all-girl rock
band I'm the drummer but we're really
new to this whole rock band thing do you
have any wisdom to share about being in
a band uh you do you answer this John
you spend a lot of time in bands I've
never been in a band Hank's been in a
band his whole life and I've always been
jealous I've always wanted to be a rock
and roll star I've always wanted to like
feel the
energy of an audience like singing back
the lyrics to me I've always wanted that
tragically I am unable to play any
musical instrument even remotely
competently like I can't even play bass
well enough to get into Hank green and
the perfect strangers and I can't sing
on key so I've just I've had to spend my
whole life on the outside looking in at
the rock band world desperately jealous
of my brother so Hank tell Katy how to
be in a rock band travel the country
have people love you Oh God crowd-surf
I'm so jealous
you've crowd surfed okay I have three
corrections now first you have crowd
surfed second I have not been in a band
my whole life though I did spend quite a
lot of time in High School in the band
meaning the marching band and third I
think Paul - George is going to be very
upset to hear you say that you don't
have enough talent to even be the bass
player because bass players have very
important jobs and very difficult jobs
and our our artists like any other
artist people diss it on bass players
all the time anyway III don't even Hank
I can't even tell you if that's true or
not that's how little I know about bass
playing I don't even know if what I said
was offensive
[Laughter]
so yeah the the thing my the thing about
being in a band that I have discovered
is and I got into this old much older
than the average person in a band it's
all about being friends and if there
isn't that then none of it is worth it
you are if it isn't it is about having a
good time and if you are in a band that
is even remotely successful you will be
spending a huge amount of time with
these people in uncomfortable situations
but stuffed into a small space very
close by them and if you cannot figure
out really great ways to have really
great personal relationships with the
people then
it's all for naught and so that's really
what it's about and that is that is a
tremendous life skill figuring out how
to have a group of people who can do
something together who can accomplish
two things together and not get on each
other's nerves or when you do get on
each other's nerves do your best to take
care of it immediately and that is
something that you know I've learned
from my bandmates who have been in more
bands than me and for longer is that
when you're on the road especially
things start getting at all tense you
immediately have to have to recognize it
and deal with it and that I think is
actually a really great life skill that
has nothing to do really with music and
everything to do with with just any
collaborative project and and I'm
thankful to them for helping me learn
learn those skills and that lesson
that's great Hank it made me even more
jealous now it desperately want to be in
your band I can't even play the
tambourine I'm hopeless but we do have
another question Hank it comes from
Candler who asks dear John and Hank I am
the cat wait what nope nope nope I have
a cat oh that's all right give going
sorry about that
Candler is not a cat but rather has a
cat I have a cat and this afternoon
I found a lizard tail on my bedroom
floor saans lizard given that this cat
does not go outside this can only mean
one thing the lizard was already inside
and still remains in one of the deep
dark corners of the room where I plan to
sleep how do you suggest I cope with my
feared that this tailless reptilian will
end up on my face during the night
well first off good news Candler you're
not a cat now that I mean that's a huge
development a second secondly
attentively the wizard is already dead
yes well not necessarily no the cat ate
that lizard Hank the lizard is probably
inside of the cat yeah no at this point
the lizard is inside of the litter box
having been pooped out by the cat it's
but it is a potential that there is a
tailless lizard who has succeeded in
using its floppy
removable tail to escape from the cat No
no there is a lizard in your house who
is a who is has no interest in you at
all and will never ever do anything
unpleasant to you that's true though
don't worry about it either way
but there is an underlying fear that I
can relate to as I can relate to most
underlying fears which is that when
things from outside appear inside it is
very stressful for some people including
me like I have no problem with mice when
they are outside I have no problem with
bats when they are outside almost no
animal properly scares me when it is in
its appropriate place which is outdoors
but almost every non pet animal
terrifies me indoors like if I see a
mouse outside I'm like oh it's a mouse
if I see a mouse inside it is a
level-one emergency I I relate to this
and I think that there is something
psychological about it about like sort
of how we have how we have decided our
like our enclosed spaces should be and
when that is violated it feels like a
personal violation but I definitely
think that there are animals who I would
be terrified to be near by a nor outside
and a number of Oh certainly not most
whales but I don't know a mountain lion
on alligator a hippopotamus a bison
let me just tell you Hank here in
Indianapolis the number of like outdoor
hippopotamus attacks is very low well I
hope the number I I hope the number of
indoor hippopotamus attacks is also very
low very low it's very near zero Hank
did I ever tell you about the Rhino that
escaped from the zoo in Central Europe
no before I tell the story I just want
to acknowledge that this is what Bill
Clinton once called a high-class problem
and I and I understand that but ok as I
may have mentioned on the podcast before
Hank there is is nothing that I have
ever done in my life
that I found as horrible as a press
junket which are these days when you sit
for 12 or 14 hours in a place and every
six minutes a reporter comes in and they
ask you
exact same questions and then they leave
and one minute later a different
reporter comes in and asks you questions
for six minutes only it's the same
questions all day long mm-hmm and I
found it intensely stressful and
terrifying and unpleasant and NAT wolf
and I were in these press junkets
together on both the Fault in Our Stars
and Paper Towns movies and during the
Paper Towns press junkets people started
like testing whether or not we were
properly friends with each other
by like quizzing us about each other and
a lot of times people would say what's
your favorite animal or what's your
spirit animal or whatever and we would
have to like write down our answers
separate from each other and then show
them and at the time a hippopotamus or
possibly a rhinoceros had just escaped
from a zoo in Prague I think and so
whenever we were asked that question we
would both answer a rhinoceros recently
escaped from a zoo in Prague and people
would be very impressed at how well we
knew each other Oh who's wondering how
that was gonna get around back to to the
question which was that there's a lizard
in this person's house but we got we got
two animals you know as I was telling
that story Hank I realized that it's one
of those stories that is mostly funny to
not wolf in myself well hopefully he's a
listener of the pod but at the very
least it was fun for you you know I
think I think listeners of the podcast
are like why didn't a determined upon
yeah well we don't he doesn't do
anything we we require him to sometimes
do things that are not the best for the
podcast because it's the best for us and
who matters in the end but John so true
that's true but by the way Nick feel
free to cut all of this so what was the
point
ah the point was that I'm not afraid of
hippopotami or rhinoceri because there
are none of them outside in Indianapolis
outside animals right fine inside
animals are terrifying and I think that
speaks to our kind of collective
obsession with the sterilization of the
world and especially like in indoors and
a feeling that
nature rather than being something we
are part of is kind of a contaminant all
right
well yes okay we does a surprisingly
deep place where you ended up there John
I've got another question
it's from Ray who asks dear Hank and
John my aged professor thanks for
putting that in there Ray is always
telling off her students namely me for
putting our laptops on our laps instead
of on a table she's adamant in her
belief that doing so is quote killing
our genitals I know that she is wrong
because my genitals have not yet
succumbed to the sweet embrace of
inescapable death however could she be
correct in thinking that continuously
having my laptop on my lap is going to
make me less fertile in some way is the
heat damaging my reproductive organs are
my gametes dying why is oh why is it
called a laptop if you're not meant to
put it on your lap well Ray I can only
speak from personal experience I have
two children and I have had my laptop on
my lap since 1991 now I've got to read
to you from from the snopes.com article
right now John a 2004 study from the
State University of New York at Stony
Brook involving 29 men ranging in age
from 21 to 35 years old found that
fellows who used laptop computers rested
on their laps for an hour raised their
scrotal temperatures by as much as 5
degrees Fahrenheit since other studies
have demonstrated links between
temperature increases and significant
reductions in sperm production
the SUNY study concluded long-term use
of laptops by teenage boys and men could
be reproductively damaging mmm could be
mmm the Snopes the Snopes article calls
it undetermined so you know it may be if
you're trying at the moment to make a
baby then don't do that but I think that
it's probably not a huge deal I mean
also do not use this for birth control
now I'm now I'm worried although I'm not
worried at all because I have no desire
to have any more children so if anything
I need to keep my laptop on at all times
but as as I screamed earlier do not use
this for birth control when I was in
high school there was a there
is a myth going around that yellow
number five the dye that they used in
Mountain Dew would reduce people's sperm
counts and I don't know if that's true
or not but I do know that some people
said well good enough for me I'm not
trying to make it a girl pregnant anyway
and that translated into drink lots of
mountain dew and you can't get a girl
pregnant which is not a true thing not
not an effective method of birth control
don't do that an effective method of
birth control I can yes yes as a father
as a protip who is also an occasional
Mountain Dew drinker I can confirm now I
think this question comes from Gabe who
writes Dear John and Hank every few
weeks there's a high profile news story
of some horrible injustice being
committed I'm a college student and I
feel like there's very little I can do
other than tweet my outrage but I'm
pretty sure that doesn't help much is
there anything I can do that makes a
real difference well that is a big and
difficult and very complicated question
and one that I'm sure our advice on will
be exceptionally dubious yeah the first
thing that I want to say though Hank is
that it feels at least to me right now
in American life like life is getting
much much worse but in fact that is not
the case at least not in any kind of
straightforward way and I want to
underscore that because I don't want
people to feel hopeless ten years ago it
was impossible if you wanted to marry
someone of your sex to get married the
murder rate in the United States is much
lower than it was 15 years ago or 30
years ago or 40 years ago more people
have health insurance help me out Hank
what are other things that are getting
better people live longer healthier
lives around the world infant mortality
has declined more in the last 20 years
than in any 20-year period in human
history I mean even something as simple
as like divorce rates going down
indicates a like a increase in stability
of the you know like that that we would
never have that that that seems kind of
like oh that's not how it is
of course divorce rates are going up but
in
fact they aren't and fewer people are
getting divorced now than they used to
because there's more stability and
families and that's great
so the the yes that is a good place to
start that it's not hopeless and people
are working hard to make the world
better and that is a thing that has been
going on for 200,000 years and continues
right now and that's really hard to
identify and yes some weeks are much
worse than others and and make us and
have these you and and will leave scars
on our nation forever and we will never
never feel the same way that we did
before this weekend I've that's how I
feel
like I feel like that this will this is
going to be one of those moments that
changes me not just what happened you
know not just the assault at pulse in
Orlando but also the death of Christina
Grimmie who was murdered at post show
signing which is the thing that I just
did for you know two weeks in a row over
and over again every night and and loved
doing and had a wonderful time doing and
you know that is a you know a tremendous
like has an outsized impact on me
personally because you know I knew her
and and because that's what we do that's
like our thing and feels very very real
and very yeah
anyway the Hannah Hart made a video this
week that I think answers this question
fairly well which is that of course we
we can do things we are lucky enough to
live in a country where you know the way
that the country is run is directly
informed by the people of the country
and it can feel I think especially to
young people who see the way that the
country's been going and and the way
that you know things currently function
that that there isn't a lot of ways to
get yourself into that process and
affect it but I think the faster and the
and the more dedicated you can be to
doing that to and and potentially not
and like not just being angry at the
current state of things but
actually trying to get into how the
current state of things works and to
affect it from the inside the better so
the younger you can do that the better
because not only will it be tools that
you are building for the future but also
that kind of that kind of you know a
perspective that young people only young
people can have which is that this is
unacceptable and we cannot let the world
continue this way which is just much
more common when you have when you are
sort of first understanding you know how
like the problems that the world faces
rather than like someone maybe my age
who has seen good things happen and has
an is like oh well this is pretty good
compared to how it was when I was a kid
you know that that Drive I think is is
more more likely to be to come from from
the younger generation and I very much
want that passion and energy to get to
have the tools that people who have an
established connection in the world of
politics to utilize those same tools and
those tools really are organizing and
connecting with your representatives in
ways that they understand which is not
angry tweet right necessarily though in
the future it will be more angry tweets
than than it is now
will have an effect but that way is
organizing groups of people together
talking to the staffers of of the people
who represent you voting in ways that
that make those people know that you are
an important voting bloc and that your
opinions do matter and that they
understand that this group of people
this connected group of people has I a
has you know can like can affect the
outcome of an election and those are the
things that change this country and yeah
and it can seem dirty and gross
sometimes to even be interacting with a
system that you see has has supported
injustice for decades but
and injustice and bad policy but but
that's how change happens and that is
how it has happened for the entire
history of America and we have done you
know we have made this country better
and we have made this world better we
have made bad decisions but we have made
I think more good decisions than bad
yeah I certainly think the United States
is a freer and fairer place than it was
when it was formed I want to underscore
something that Hank said I think it's
incredibly important to reach out to
your representatives both your Congress
people your Senators but also your local
representatives let them know the issues
that matter to you I know it is hard it
is hard to call strangers especially
hard to call strangers who seem to be
powerful people who are separate from
you and distant from you but I it's so
important they don't listen to Twitter
the same way they listen to phone calls
that's why so much political
organization revolves around calling
representatives I also think it's
incredibly important to vote not just in
presidential elections not just to focus
on who's the President of the United
States but to focus on who's your state
senator who's your state Rep who are
your city and county council people
because those people have an outsize say
in what actually happens in the u.s.
from choosing the districts the shapes
of the districts that you vote in so in
in essence choosing the party of the
representative you're gonna have four
for US Congress but also in many many
other ways I think it's incredibly
important and and I I think sometimes
with our national our focus on national
politics we lose that focus on local
politics that makes a big difference in
the everyday lives of people right down
to something like protecting LGBT people
from discrimination in the state that I
live in Indiana there is no statewide
protection for LGBT people there is no
law that says that you can't fire
someone for being gay that's ludicrous
right and that's not something that
we're going to be able to fix nationally
it's something that we have to fix in
Indiana and we fix that by making the
case to our local representatives that
this is unacceptable that this
is part of a larger pattern of
discrimination and violence that goes
back to the very beginning of the
history of the United States and its
relationship with LGBT people and so I
think that stuff is incredibly important
yeah and and it can be overwhelming at
first but to me it's kind of like an
assignment in in being a citizen of your
country wherever you are if you live in
a democratic place that like you like
this is it's not a requirement but it is
like if you don't like the way things
are violent overthrow of the government
is not going to happen and even if it
could it would be a bad idea and so if
you want things to change you have to
learn how to make them change and that
that is a process and it involves doing
things that are uncomfortable I remember
the first time I called a representative
on the phone I left a message and I was
like sweating and I was like it's it's
an intense and kind of difficult thing
which is I think like that is part of
why it is you know why it is weighed
more heavily by the people at those
offices and by the the politicians
themselves because they know that a
tweet is easy but a phone call is hard
and so when people care enough to call
that's when they know that an issue is
becoming more important so like that
that is like the like because it is hard
is the reason why it matters more in
some ways it's also because of course
like these people are often older and
and are like and also like bureaucracies
tend to change more slowly than the rest
of the world so yeah I there's apps are
absolutely things you can do and by
virtue of living in in the developed
world you are a powerful person and you
are far more powerful than the average
person on earth and that is or a you
know kind of scary sometimes but it it
is a real thing and it can seem not real
but but it is only not it only seems not
real because you know sort of caught up
in the middle of it and feel
sort of sort of like we're being washed
over by this giant wave of crap so yes
thank you for the great question and
sorry that John and I talked for a real
long time about it I do want to say one
more thing actually I I want to
underscore that we have big and real
problems in the United States on a lot
of different topics and that real
people's lives are negatively deeply
negatively affected by those real
problems some of them are policy
problems some of them are social
problems we have you know some of them
are a complicated mix I do think that
one other thing we can do is we can try
to model better discourse we can try to
do a better job on an individual level
of listening to people of listening to
people we disagree with of not shouting
them down of not trying to prove them
wrong but of trying to find ways to work
together to understand each other to
feel that we are in this together
because we deeply are and to listen
better because I don't I don't think
right now in online discourse and maybe
you'll disagree with me Hank but I do
not think that we are doing a good job
of listening to each other and I think
it is much to the harm of the overall
quality of American life both political
life and social life I do not disagree
with you let me tell you and I but but I
also have to say that I am I also do
that and I know that you do too we all
do it and me too I just did it a couple
days ago I lost my temper and screamed
at someone and I yeah and and you know
what it did not change that person's
beliefs Adam one of it I just did it
recently as well on my last vlog
brothers video I left a nasty comment to
somebody who often nasty comments and I
was like that didn't help anything it
didn't work but it made me feel good for
a moment it gave me a tiny moment so
just excitement and then just decreased
the quality of overall my overall life a
tiny bit in the long run so and possibly
the whole world so yeah it's not worth
it let's move on to another question I'm
tired of this
getting distressed okay this one is from
Rachel who asks dear Hank and John over
the last year I have consumed a lot of
fanfiction and I get made fun of by my
friends for it a lot a few of my friends
have called fanfiction a bad thing but
I'm not sure I agree well sometimes it
can be weird I feel like it allows
people to get their voice out about what
they're writing about and thinking about
what are your thoughts on fanfiction
reading and/or writing I am strongly Pro
fanfic yes I have written a little bit
of fanfiction myself and I very much
enjoyed doing it and I've read
fanfiction and I very much enjoy reading
and I think that it's a great tool for
you know expressing passion and
community and and coalescing fandoms and
I also think it's a really great tool to
help people learn how to write better
and and be better readers and I you know
it also enhances these great worlds that
we want to spend more time in but
sometimes can't because there are no
more Harry Potter books coming out yeah
I also really like fan fiction and I
have also written some of it pseudonym
initially in sort of as little breaks
from my proper writing career and I've
found it very enjoyable I don't want to
tell you what my pseudonym is Hank but
it's Ryan
it's Ryan Ryan Ryan Ryan sin' son of
Ryan father of Ryan uncle and cousin to
Ryan I really I've enjoyed my
experiments with writing fanfiction and
I love reading it I have to say I am so
deeply flattered when people write
fanfiction about my books and I remember
at one point my publisher came to me and
said you know do you want to shut this
down do you want people from publishing
this stuff and I was like no I want to
send them I want to send them thank-you
gifts and money like I think this is
amazing this is very good this is good
good news and I every time anybody cares
enough about my book to try to extend
the world of it or to extend the
characters of it it's such a gift to me
and I'm very grateful for it then having
said that Hank I would like to
on to a new question this one is from
Holly who writes Dear John and Hank one
phrase has bothered me for years but
John using it in the last episode made
me hope he could explain it to me
why when someone is saying something do
they begin it with quote unquote
shouldn't it be quote whatever they are
saying unquote why do people say unquote
and others say end quote are both
correct
help me understand well Holly end quote
is incorrect ah and I know it's
incorrect because I don't use it and the
the ultimate style guide is the style
guide I was taught by my parents
we all know the real English style guide
who was formed in Orlando Florida by
Mike and Sidney Greene
in about 1982 to 1985
so that just just saying quote quote
unquote and then you say the thing is
just a way of saving time right quote
unquote and then you can kind of tell
when the quote ends so you don't have to
say quote and then say this thing and
then say unquote at the end of it
that would just be I would be sort of
weirder well III can never think of I
use quote unquote a lot except I can i
can't currently think of an example well
but why don't you just say quote like I
get it there's also going to be an end
of the quote someday right it will be
implied by your by the tone of your
speech so yes say and Charles Darwin
said quote and then say what Charles
Darwin said well in that scenario I
would say Charles Darwin said quote and
and etc but when I say quote unquote
it's usually about one or two words that
I feel are being misused or I feel I was
my voice I want to insert it into
someone else's voice uh-huh the way that
I would use air quotes right so when I
say quote unquote I'm basically saying
air quotes right right right
as for why I say it again I say it
because that's how my parents taught me
to talk when I was a child and then and
then as far as saying unquote verses end
quote it's not an egg corn I don't know
all I know is that quote unquote is
correct
I have decided that it is correct like I
feel like end quote is the thing that
happened because people thought that we
were saying end quote when they were
saying unquote but in either case it
totally works
which is fine and this is the the the
and and so like that entering accepted
language usage would be fine but I love
that this can be called a neg corn
because it is a a word that people miss
heard but the miss hearing makes sense
and that egg corn being what people
thought someone was saying when they
were saying a corn but they thought it
was an egg corn because it looked kind
of like a kernel of corn but was hard
and oval er like an egg I think we
should start calling acorns egg corns
now that I've thought about it why do we
call acorns acorns what a weird word I
don't know but I have a more important
thing to say which is that the word oval
either comes from the word ovum or the
word ovum comes from the word oval and
I'd never realized that from until now
and now I want to know today's podcast
is brought to you by the word ovum or
possibly the word oval we're not sure
yet
it comes from if indeed comes from the
word egg so it started with egg and then
you went from egg to oval shape so it so
it turns out that today's brought to you
by ovum's or OVA or OV i not very good
at night lat
yeah good good good good John this
podcast is also brought to you by
Katie's rock band
Katie's rock band they didn't tell me
what the name of the band was but
hopefully they won't have a big fight
about it when they are trying to
establish it yeah hey it occurs to me
that may be the number one piece of
advice we could have given Katie about
her rock band is that she needs to start
doing a better job of marketing her rock
band by for instance including its name
in her email to us yes that would have
that would have helped if anybody wants
to help named Katie's rock band you can
leave that on twitter twitter hashtag
dear Hank and John that's a great idea
Hank we should name Katie's rock band
yeah we did you want to you know I
already have I already have a name for
it okay ocupado
what else is the podcast brought to you
by John today's podcast is also brought
to you by Mountain Dew mountain dew not
effective birth control as it turns out
and finally this podcast is brought to
you by the wiggling tail of the lizard
that is now inside of canned lers litter
box Candler a cat who's not a cat whose
cats ada lizard and made its owner
afraid of the lizard that got ate that's
the worst
brought to you by that we've ever done
no I think I think in the end though
that sometimes we have to show our rough
edges oh yeah God knows this podcast
doesn't have enough rough edges great
what we're really lacking around here is
rough edges I don't want it to get too
polished John oh yeah god forbid all
right I got another question that this
one's from last week's set and I wanted
to answer it so I apologize John that
this isn't in your document it says it's
from Jackie who asks dear Hank and John
growing up most of my friends were
forced to learn a musical instrument by
their parents or school our lives were
much more regimented as children if your
mom said you had to practice you just
had to practice I never had that
pressure to gain that skill and I'm
worried I'm at a disadvantage my
question is do you have any dude was
dubious advice for those of us picking
up a hobby who aren't between the ages
of 7 and 15 what do I do when I want to
give up and my parents aren't there to
force me to practice I actually started
to play guitar when I was 24 years old
and I was had never done it before and
here's the thing that it's all about you
have to get through a period of time
when it is not fun and in order to do
that you can either have a great deal of
motivation and self-control or you can
pay a person to make you do it and to be
disappointed in you if you don't which
is what I did his name was James and he
was my guitar teacher and I took about
six months of guitar lessons and it got
me through the hard part until I could
play some of my favorite songs and sing
the
and it was fun so that that you know if
you if you can't afford that then you've
got to get when it karen kavett s-- you
know daily calendars where you mark off
that you did something every day and you
never let yourself not do it and find
other motivational techniques like that
but but once you get through that
initial process you know i'm still not
like a virtuosic guitar player or
anything i can i can't even do any
finger picking I just play chords but I
have a really good time doing it and
that's what music is about isn't it also
about being good though it's a yeah I
mean it's about it's about progressing I
think I think that's part of the fun
part of learning any skill getting
better and and that is a source of great
joy and I think that all people like
like having something in your life that
you are on the path to mastery which of
course is the thing that ever happens
does increase life satisfaction and I
think I would recommend it to anyone
whether it's guitar or poetry or yeah
management no I absolutely agree that
like feeling like you're progressing at
something you care about is a huge part
of having a high quality of life at
least for me like it's the it's kind of
the central thing and when I feel like
I'm not progressing mm-hmm at the things
that I care about I get very frustrated
yes
so Hank before we get to the news from
Mars and AFC Wimbledon I just want to
read one response email that we got
because it's absolutely fantastic in a
recent podcast you told the story about
the time that your bike got stolen do
you remember yes I do it did not it did
not in fact get stolen it did not in
fact get stolen what in fact it happened
to it I had locked it up downtown and
then and then walked home and forgotten
correct so this is Emma Stone for four
months for several months yes this is
Emma story Hank exclamation point while
listening to your podcast I got excited
for about 30 seconds because of our
almost identical stolen bike stories
until you got to the part where you
realized you had left it somewhere a
month after my bike was stolen in real
life I found it chained to a pole next
door to my house first
I just kind of let it happen because I
felt like they must need money more than
I needed the bike I see it as kind of a
win-win they got some money somebody
else got a nice bike and I got a story
to tell Emma Hank is a better person
than any of us really oh man I
you didn't even buy your own bike back
you could have been like hey yeah I'd
like to buy this bike but can I get a
bit of a discount because of how it's
mine I mean maybe 20 percent off I don't
like to nominate people for sainthood
Hank it's not it's not in my nature but
I think that we should have a talk with
Pope Benedict personal friend about
possibly making Emma a saint I don't
know how well do you know Pope Benedict
tank uh not at all though I do know some
people who have talked with him because
several youtubers got to go and meet the
Pope yeah well I have a cousin who is a
Catholic priest so the Pope and I are
acquainted right yes that is how that
works I believe that is correct
Hank is there any news from Mars this
week oh you know what John there is I
you may be surprised to find out
so Elon Musk has provided some new
details on his mission to Mars his plans
for how to get humans to Mars so the way
that Mars works is it goes around the
Sun and so does earth which means that
occasionally they are very far apart
because Mars will be on the other side
of the Sun and occasionally they are
pretty close together and that happens
once every two years that Mars and Earth
get close enough to like close together
so that makes it a much cheaper and
quicker trip so that the next time that
will happen is in 2018 so it's basically
2018 2020 2022 2024 Elon Musk wants to
send his first unmanned spacecraft to
Mars in 2018 it is Wow as soon as that
my guess is that it will probably be
2020 because that that is a very near
target but he he wants to have it
launched on a rocket that has never
launched before called the Falcon Heavy
and it will be using the dragon
spaceship which would
be the the the spacecraft I should say
the heaviest thing to ever land on Mars
by a factor of 10 and the the plan then
thereafter would be if that first
mission would go in 2018 and then 2022
they would be sending more supply
missions that would be like these are
things that people are going to use once
they get there so they're not even there
will be some science experiments going
along with those things some robotic
experiments but there will also be
things that will aid human explorers as
they get to the surface of Mars and that
would happen again in twenty twenty
twenty and twenty twenty two with more
missions that would have more payloads
and I think that his plan is that as
soon as 2022 there would be humans
humans colonists in what he refers to as
the Mars colonial transporter designed
to bring people to Mars now that seems
outlandish ly optimistic but that is
Elon Musk for you it is very difficult
to say how this effort would be funded
of course his plan is to significantly
decrease the cost that does not make it
cheap but I think that like on the
inside
estimate SpaceX is plan Elon Musk's plan
is to get it like I would think that if
they have everything go very well they
could be actually sending human people
to Mars by 2024 and he continues to
outline this plan saying the goal is not
to have those people go and then come
back and then have have gone to Mars the
way we did with the moon but have the
people go and come back but always be
sending new people as well and then
establish a permanent station that would
be always staffed on the surface of Mars
and he says it is dangerous and people
will probably die and they will know
that and they will pave the way and
ultimately it will be very safe to go to
Mars and it will be very comfortable but
that will be many years in the future
Wow
I mean is there a way that you and I can
make a bet right now as to whether or
not there will be any humans on Mars by
2024 well the launch will happen in 2024
so the land they would be landing in 22
five I I would not know what I'll give
you an extra year I'll give you till
2026 I'll give you ten years from today
do you believe that there will be humans
on Mars well that's not how the Mars
missions work as we as we discussed
previously it's once every two years so
iw 2025 or 2027 or 2029 it will
definitely not be 2026 but you just said
that the idea is that there will be
permanent staffing well yes so there
would be some there would be people
still there but it would not increase my
chances if you gave me 2026 is what I'm
saying it wouldn't make it it wouldn't
make it more likely all right I'll give
you 20 27 all right can you give me
better than even odds I will not give
you better than even odds I'm asking you
to throw in your lot with Elon Musk and
believe that in 11 years there will be a
human
I will even say it's okay if the human
is dead a human alive or dead on Mars Oh
God well I think we should let our
listeners suggest the stakes okay yes
the stakes do not have to be monetary
please suggest the stakes at on Twitter
hashtag dear Hank and John or on our
patreon patreon comm slash dear Hank and
John speaking of our patreon Hank
there's this ridiculous picture of you
that's circulating with the announcement
of you've just created a new nonprofit
congratulations the internet creators
guilt and it's going to be an
organization that advocates for online
creators and increases transparency in
in their business dealings and stuff
it's very exciting but there's this
picture of you that's circulating that
I'm gonna put on the patreon and you
look ridiculous Wow what which one is
it's the one where somehow you you're at
a conference and you've managed to oh
god yeah so that it's like you're
wearing it as if it were a tiny Miss
America sash it's the most ludicrous
picture of you I've ever seen if you
want to go to the you don't have to
subscribe or anything I'm just putting
this up for the sheer joy of sharing
Hanks ridiculousness with you it's at
patreon.com slash dear Hank and John ah
yeah I mean I'm serious I did Hank to
find out whether or not there's going to
be a human on Mars by 2017
and and indeed to have our listener
suggest stakes in this bed it finally
gives me something that I can get
excited about preventing humans from
going to Mars by 2027 oh god I finally
got a mission on life I've got to
sabotage Elon Musk's mission oh yeah I'm
gonna become the anti anti Elon Musk I'm
gonna start like advocating for
decreasing the amount of funding we're
spending on space who wants to go to
space when we've got a great planet
right here can we cut can we call you
like Leon mush are you gonna D ant i'il
on musk Leon mush
oh man I'm starting a Twitter right now
twitter.com slash Leon mah swear I'm
gonna do nothing but try to destroy Elon
Musk whole life so that I can prevent
him from sending people to Mars and win
some stupid bet with you okay there is
some news from AFC Wimbledon this week
it's sad news these days all the news
seems to be said we're going up Hank
it's the most improbable thing we've had
to submit a new description of the
podcast to iTunes because we're now a
third tier soccer team but not a fourth
year soccer team but today it was
announced that ah da Aziz who as a
striker perhaps best known not just for
his goals but for the song that
Wimbledon fans sang about him your
defense is terrified as Easy's on fire
ha ha ha it has been announced is
leaving AFC Wimbledon to sign for a
Scottish team called Partick Thistle
that I once mistakenly called Patrick
thistle and lots of people had given me
crap about it over the years but it's
Partick Thistle so ah de Aziz still a
really young player I think he's just 22
was a really important striker for AFC
Wimbledon but usually played off the
bench and I think is headed to Partick
Thistle because he wants to be a starter
so I wish him luck
we all wish him luck he was a huge part
of the Wimbledon season that led to
promotion but this is another loss
another player leaving and we haven't
yet heard word of many players coming in
or any players coming in actually so
it's a little bit scary but I trust Neil
Ardley our beloved manager and I'm sure
that it will be fine
but that is the news from AFC Wimbledon
we are bidding adieu to a odd a Aziz in
fact now Hank we've lost both of our
strikers named Adebayo
Otto by walk and phenoix and Otto bio
Aziz so everything is changing light
that is the nature of life by 2027
Wimbledon will be in the Premier League
how much money do we need to give them
for them to get get a bunch of people to
replace the people hundreds of thousands
of dollars I don't have that do you want
to do a bet that that AFC Wimbledon
won't be in the Premier League in 2027 I
do I think we will be in the Premier
League in 2027 absolutely yes no doubt
okay so what's so is there another bet
here I mean do you really want to bet
against a team owned by its fans that
had to reform in 2002 and had open
tryouts on Wimbledon Common you want to
bet against that happening
you're a dark person Hank green you just
bet against humanity' going to another
plan is trying to bet against what I see
as dangerous ill-advised missions to
Mars
I don't even actually believe that but
now I really want to win the bet so I'm
just gonna become like a hardcore and
you know what I Hank I've heard actually
that going to Mars can be bad for your
sperm count just like putting a laptop
on your lap no that is definitely true
that it could it could very easily be
bad for your sperm count and also all of
your other accounts oh boy Hank what did
we learn today we learned that if you're
trying to have a baby then putting a
laptop on your lap is not necessarily
the best idea but if you're trying not
to have a baby putting a laptop on your
lap will not actually help you achieve
that goal
we learned that the science is still out
on putting a laptop on your lap we also
learned that Candler is not a cat nope
not a cat with a person with a cat and
we learned that John Green has a secret
identity under which he writes
fanfiction and that secret identity is
Ryan Ryan sand son of Ryan and of course
we learned that Elon Musk will not be
going to Mars by 2027
not if Leon masa is anything to say
about it well I got a log out of my
Twitter so I can get twitter.com slash
Leon moss all right thank you thank you
John for podcasting with me thank you
everyone for listening our podcast is
edited by Nicholas Jenkins
rosianna halse rojas helps out with the
questions our intern is Claudia Morales
the dear Hank and John music is by
gunnarolla and as they say in our
hometown don't forget to be awesome
I forgot to tell people where they could
email us Oh Hank you're better than that
you can email us the dear Hank and John
com did that count know if that was our
email that's but it isn't so you still
haven't succeeded you can email us at
Hank and John at gmail.com and as they
say in our hometown don't forget to be
awesome